good morning believe nation today's
message is have the right attitude over
to you and if Rosella I see everyday
people with this mentality that the
world owes them something and it's
popular now to talk about entitlement
and everybody deserves and all these
different things that people like to
[ __ ] and cry about but people come at
life with the wrong attitude okay and
and they don't like hearing the truth
and the truth of the matter is this the
world owes you nothing the world doesn't
think you're special like your mom does
it doesn't think you're a delicate
little flower it doesn't care about you
now with that being said the world
doesn't hate you it doesn't want you to
fail it just is
okay and I see so many people going
through their life with this
overwhelming feeling of either a the
world owes me something or B the world
hates me and the reality is it's neither
and what's common amongst this group of
people that I find is that both these
groups of people that I find is that
they're missing the understanding of
what it means to be successful and let
me let me get at exactly what the cause
of this is the cause of this is they're
selfish they're self-centered they're
self focused they're only worried about
what they see in the mirror and they go
around through their daily life trying
to manipulate the world in a way that's
going to serve them but here's the thing
guys if that's the way you go through
life if you go through life trying to
figure out a way for the world to get
you something for you to be successful
you know at the expense of
or for you to get ahead at the expense
of others your success or any success
that you're able to build or momentum
you're able to build is going to be very
short-lived guys and that's that's not
the right way to do things okay that's
why you see the same people you know who
make money real fast lose money real
fast that's why you see the same people
who you know have a little bit of
success and then go back to the way they
were and then they might find a new
quote-unquote thing to do and they make
a little bit of money and they go back
to the way they were and the problem
with this mentality guys is that it's a
mentality that is not of service okay
and if you want to be truly successful
in life you have to be selfless and you
have to understand that being selfless
and being of service to other people is
the only true way to find long-term
success watching Annie speak reminds me
of a quote that I found recently where
it says that you are entitled to nothing
but you can earn anything and I think
that's a really important message to
keep in our mind and have that as our
mindset forever you are entitled to
nothing but you can earn everything I
think it's easy to get locked into a
trap where you feel like you've put in
the work you're you're hustling you're
grinding you're killing yourself to pour
all your energy into this thing and it's
not working out and so you feel like I I
deserve to get a result here and I share
your frustration in my first software
company I was making $300 a month
because I couldn't figure things out and
it wasn't for lack of effort I was
putting it in to what every waking hour
almost was going into making this
business work and everything else I
invested my time into yielded some kind
of results it wasn't it I'm slacking off
and I'm not seeing results I can you can
accept that right if you know you're not
putting in the hustle and you're not
getting results well you can kind of
accept that but when you're working hard
when you're investing everything you
have into something and you're not
getting results it's easy to start to
adopt the attitude that I should be
getting better
the
owes me something here now come on guys
I put in the hustle
I should be getting results and it's a
dangerous spot to be we're the important
lesson is to understand that you're just
not providing enough value yet and it's
not from the amount of work necessary
that you put in in maybe you're you're
putting it in the number of hours that's
great
but maybe you're focusing on the wrong
things maybe your your product or
service isn't good enough yet maybe
you're not doing enough marketing yet
maybe you're doing a hundred things
wrong that could be better in your
business in my company at the start we
weren't doing enough marketing
partnerships
the partnerships helped save the
business but we weren't doing enough of
that and so we were struggling
struggling struggling struggling till we
finally started making some partnerships
and that helped us take off I look at my
youtube channel now I love what I'm
doing on YouTube I think it's an amazing
channel if I wasn't making it I would be
a subscriber and a daily viewer of this
channel for the content all the pulling
all this knowledge from all these great
people I look at my channel to think why
why am I only out at four hundred fifty
thousand subscribers why am I not at
five million subscribers with all the
value that's coming across you not just
for entrepreneurs but anybody why do I
not have more subscribers this is
probably frustration for a lot of you
guys why do I not have more money why do
I have more customers why don't I have
more people following me I don't deserve
it I need to get better my videos need
to get better my topics need to get
better you know the SEO needs to get
better the engage we need to get better
everything I make has to get better and
if I fall into the trap of YouTube sucks
you know their algorithm sucks you know
my stuff is amazing you guys need to
recognize that if that's the pole that I
fall into that's a trap then I stop
focusing on the real problem which is
mean which is the actions that I'm doing
and then I will never see the result the
moment I turn into complaining mode the
moment you turn into complaining mode
then you're never going to get out of it
where it's understanding and accepting
that you're not producing something that
people care enough about yet and that's
brutal and that sucks to hear especially
when you're putting in so many hours and
then love into this thing but what
you're making is not good enough yet and
you need to make it better I need to
make it better
I deserve everything that I have and I
don't deserve more until I create
something better and I think adopting
that mentality instead of feeling like
I'm entitled to something and
complaining that helps me continue to
grow will help you continue to grow as
well so the question that a today is
around having the right mindset right
attitude what attitude do you feel you
need to break what attitude do you feel
needs to be improved for you to have
more success as an entrepreneur for you
personally leave it in the comments
below I'm going to join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day I believe in you I hope
you continue to believe in yourselves
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon